[Music]
there's a veneration related to culture
and that's whether they develop the
nanda thoughts even humans for that
matter but whether the Neanderthals
developed trade Commerce let me read
just a one-liner john hawkes he's a guru
right minute tell you what these guys
are really up to or how much they really
know ya know those in a couple of cases
are trading shells seashells that came
from fossil deposits and they trade them
over long distances pretty shells for
furs or meat what do you think sounds
obviously ridiculous that's likely like
some newest stuff historically this year
let me tell you mine give you my five
cents worth commerce is something only
humans develop you know chimps and
gorillas to this day or angry to they
don't have Congress but the point here
is that Congress is something we develop
not only after agriculture way after way
after because agriculture first was
subsistence agriculture that we develop
commercial agriculture it's a high-level
development these guys are talking about
fifty thousand years ago that the never
thought about trading seashells or furs
or why don't cover themselves why would
you trade seashells for food because
they're saying that see they use them as
collars like they have holes in them and
the question is these seashells for
have a different explanation the
question is these guys try to interpret
it this way because they want to
introduce their admixture theory and
they're saying look if we traded
seashells for furs and for meat and I
need market and women swap women then
clearly you know we had they have growth
cells
and casinos it just shows you how much
these people really understand their
apology they have no street-smart well
it's not a mystery smile it's like
they're just they're basically assuming
the inner thoughts or just other humans
language sex like oh yeah yeah they were
really Playboy magazines or something
you know and you know what is definitely
known these people are and there's a
final one and that's the contagious
diseases mass diseases you know we
brought this we came from Africa and we
brought all these diseases and killed
them with these diseases but obviously
it's got to do with that mixture how
does that go through that sounds like
the war because I had sex with them and
we during sex we gave them all these
diseases that's how it comes into play
with the sexual part it's like we
brought you know gonorrhea or something
and just gave it to them like we brought
them diseases and the poor monkeys you
know in the Artic you know they had no
defenses like the Mexicans like f6
Hannah knows when I'm fencing against
Espanyol and still have like Native
Americans yeah we did it all died out
that's the first issue that not always
do not ever do all of our species or
whatever in this case though you can
talk about the aspects not all of them
die some of them have defenses that's
one issue but the other issue is that so
then the other thought they'd give us
diseases they'd kill I ever they're more
well yeah but I mean it depends how many
we are you know we have more to lose
right if anything in fact we are going
into their environment we are taking
your bar but not them they're already in
there they were used to their diseases
you know their sedentary more or less
but we are coming from Africa and we
should be encountering new disease we
should be killed not though but there
were no master diseases you know
hunter-gatherers you're talking about
little clans of maybe 2030 people even
whenever he loves thieves you better
hang got killed everyone in the diseases
that's what I'm saying if you have a
client of like 20 people yeah if you do
get a disease they do all die was dead
but everyone else's keep high that's one
issue the other issues that not everyone
of the clan dies always almost always
someone survives oh yeah I'm gonna you
survive as the lone survivor of your
clan to survive your clan doesn't get
sick or get sick and dies it's very
straightforward yeah and again mass
diseases are something that you need
mass they never met it's a mass disease
but on a small scale there's because
that's what it is because if you have a
clan that's that's you get if that clan
gets the mass disease happens to get it
because they're all you know kind of
crammed into a cave if they get it they
just die but it's not like every clan
gets it that's why it's like it's like
it's quarantine ever every master
disease that happens to happen would be
quarantined within the clans it's not
matters yes in a sense that everyone's
in a city where everyone's talking to
everyone there's no quarantine in that
sense that's that's a different sense
like bubonic plague that kills everyone
because urban touches everyone but I
think it's smaller groups like clans if
a clan happens to get a bubonic plague
it's like they're already quarantine so
they just die off but everything else
and one issue with that also is is that
that the cease ties with true because
you know it's not like it's spreads it
would spread if you're like in a city
and with what I say mass even need mass
mass busy these guys didn't have mass
you can't really have a mass to CT that
would also be against the commerce thing
because if they did get try to pick with
diseases yeah because if you do get mass
disease yeah then it would have affected
we'd have some sort of evidence I guess
of them dying by mass diseases which
would indicate that they are actually
training and yeah Hawking everyone but
I'm assuming these are all these like
quarantined clans like classes that
don't meet or if they meet Lee they
become me like a fight fight each other
or they didn't see each other no but
what you just said is important and
let's take the Year 45,000 years ago
right then we should have you know a
layer with all the mechanicals dead they
were all killed by the sea so this so we
would find like you know a lot of skulls
you know somewhere or some cemetery word
or some cave that's got 10 10 guys dead
you know these guys died of the same you
see and we could probably figure out if
they died of the disease you know even
45,000 years later we can probably
figure out but there's no such thing
there's no such evidence of something
like that so again when you have Roman
clans you're not really hit by a disease
that's diseases really what gets you
yeah and and so it right and Roman clans
is important because these guys are
roaming you know even even if they kill
one clan and in a cave you know first
the disease dies there I still mean you
know there's such a thing but but then
you know again it's a it's too low
density to to sustaining mass disease
yet to sustain that's going because
they're not all passing it to each I
it's like if it happens to hit someone
they just die yeah you can have like
they don't want to play some kind of our
cake version of it strain you know
whatever
or you can have you know even mosquitos
yellow fever some kind of ancient
version of it if it was in their region
it would gotten used to it over time you
know they would have killed a lot of
people are dying man yeah yeah wiped out
and then others would continue
eventually the disease forms you know an
uneasy relationship with them maybe get
some sick but doesn't kill them yeah and
now you've got these Africans coming
over these these humans and the question
is what can they have brought that kill
them off you know and again we're
talking if it's sexual it's not a mass
disease you don't have to be late the
Spanish flu right it has to be something
like that because you know apparently
the Americans gave the Spaniards you
know I'm talking about the Aztecs
perhaps the Incas gave the Spaniards the
these what I call that disease sexual
disease syphilis gave gave the Europeans
syphilis they say that came from from
America but what's not one-on-one it's
not it's not something that kills off
millions of piano simple this is a is
not a mass disease it's one on one you
have sex you get it that's it you're
dead yeah but you know it doesn't affect
the whole population and so if the
disease's the Africans are the
forefathers of cro-magnons what they
brought over to the European Nana
thoughts or sexual disease I would have
killed that never phone that's it that's
the bit they're gonna kill all trade
sexual diseases you know none of it if
within the culture I cannot explain well
that is if you assume that those were
gorillas in very different from humans
I'm guessing these people think that me
and our thoughts are just like humans of
course they have to they have to make
them like humans because otherwise
everybody would question the
interbreeding you know process or
mechanism but it just you can't really
explain how humans are how species
evolved into humans in Europe exactly
the same way that it would evolve in
Africa yeah and then they bring language
in long long lost cousins Oh friends
again not really
yeah I'll see that happen especially if
the end of those you know killed other
Neanderthals
well didn't you in school of course I'm
sure
I was sure every clan was by itself
every clan was the country that's what
I'm saying I don't think that's where
the culture shock comes but it is it has
to do with culture because a lion you
know he's got his pride that's his
client right but the clan on the other
side that's his enemy another lion comes
over he's gonna make sure because you
can have a lion just come in and kill
all the males and just take over the
pride right but my point is they weren't
from me the like every other friendly
right let's let's put that out well that
looks friendly a lot of these guys are
saying that if you have a long term
relationship it's because there's
friendliness there's neighborliness
house can use way you handle em
neighborliness you can't have commerce
we're barely friendly with each other
today we're barely friendly we're the
most civilized thing that ever I hope
what super Zilla is working for your
letter and after your wife comes in your
way course to two firs
three cities
oh yeah so what should we do with them
geeks that worked at the Max Planck
Institute well let me tell you what I
think
cowabunga
[Music]